to see you this morning these numbers
continuing to go
in the wrong direction minister despite
that the tears have been in for
for quite some time now what's going
wrong
well as the health secretary said this
week the rate of growth
has slowed but still we're seeing the
virus
uptick the most important thing is to
keep targeting the virus
where it is picking up where it is
gathering momentum
which is why the targeted localized
focused approach
not just with restrictions but with the
financial support is the right approach
and that's the way we'll avoid
the rather blanket blunt uh tool of a
national lockdown which
i think is right to avoid the who has
said uh
should only be used in a reserve measure
but also from the
economic point of view it will be very
damaging so we're
but what's what's most important at this
point in time is everyone leans into
this
so where targeted measures are in place
we've got them in my own constituency we
follow the guidance meticulously
we've got local leaders uh cooperating
very closely
with the government which we've
overwhelmingly seen
mostly across the country there have
been some exceptions but mostly that
collaboration has been strong
that's the way we avoid the the rather
blunt tool of a national lockdown
there is an argument to say though that
obviously these these tier restrictions
are going to be
in place for a lot longer than the short
sharp shock of a national lockdown would
need to be to
to have the same effect so even in
economic terms
a national lockdown may make more sense
well if you look at those who've
advocated a national lockdown including
kyostama
for example but others they've never
been able to say how you get out of it
so
the idea of a short sharp circuit
breaker is frankly
uh something of an enigma no one can say
if you go into a national lockdown how
you at what point you get out of it so i
i think that would not only be damaging
it wouldn't be in economic terms it
wouldn't be the targeted approach
in epidemiological terms and it would
create great uncertainty
so we appreciate this is difficult i
know from my own constituency
the challenges the disruption the
inconvenience of being in the height
here
um but it's better to take a targeted
approach than have the blunt tool
of nationwide restrictions at the very
highest
possible level which i think a lot of
people in those areas where the virus
hasn't taken hold
would think was unfair as well as
ineffective yeah but it's it's
interesting though
you you quote sakia stamina as being one
of those in favor of a national lockdown
well sage your scientific advisory body
was in favor of a national lockdown
it can't be dismissed
no it can't be dismissed it can be
argued and tested and of course
we had the full range of options
presented by the scientists to the
government
uh with chris whittie with patrick
valance the chief scientific advisor the
chief
medical officer and ultimately of course
politicians need to take responsibility
but overwhelmingly uh our senses and i
and i think this is backed up for
example with what the world health
organization
has said is that you're far better
leaning in being absolutely committed to
targeted localized uh measures with the
financial support
than taking the blanket blunt approach
of a nationwide lockdown
if you can possibly help it so it's
absolutely right
that we strain every sinew work with
local leaders provide financial support
but target the virus where the uptick is
the most threatening and that's the
approach we're taking
we've just been talking to sir mark
walport who's as you will know is a
member of
of the sage committee and he he has more
sense than to
to tread on the toes of policy makers he
wouldn't dare do that but he did point
out
that you know throughout all of this
we've we've tend to have been about a
month behind
at mainland europe and he does point out
that france
and germany are entering national
lockdowns we see the situation in
ireland in wales of course
his his the indication is that that it
just may become necessary at some point
well the advantage in the situation you
described and us
being able to follow uh the the
situation in other countries if you like
is that we can learn the lessons from it
and the fundamental
key lesson is to lean into the localized
targeted focused measures and to make
them as effective as as possible
precisely because if we don't there is
that risk
of a nationwide lockdown which will be
damaging and is not the most targeted
way of tackling the virus so i think
you're right to point to that
i talk to my french german and
opposite numbers and around the world uh
we look to learn from the lessons and
the experience
but i think the targeted approach the
localized approach is the right way to
go but you've really got to lean in and
be committed to it
and that of course is the advice of
people like patrick valance and chris
whitty and the scientist
as well as i think making economic sense
as well
i'm interested that you said in terms of
a national lockdown no one can say how
you would come out of it
well how do you come out of tier 3
well with all of the targeted approaches
the advantage we've got is we would
examine the data
locally so there is a review process in
place
for all the tiered localized
restrictions that we've got
it allows us to look not just at
abstract national level
data but at the specific data in the
communities
and the regions affected and of course
both based on the prevalence but also
the growth rate we are able to track in
a much more
granular way what the virus is doing and
so that allows us
to ease off uh when we've made the
progress that we need to see
when the threat is abated so we we've
got we're in a much better position
to to address the point you raised to be
able to exit in a targeted responsible
way
when you take localized restrictions
precisely because we now measure the
virus on a localized basis
the government's in an unenviable an
enviable position
no one with any sense is is going to
disagree
with that you're trying to balance the
health of the nation as well as the
economic health of the nation
um is there an acknowledgement though
that things have not always
worked to plan i mean you eat out to
help out was was so
widely applauded businesses liked it
though the
concerns the economic benefit was pretty
short-lived the university of warwick's
study out today
says it drove up spikes of covert 19
infections by between 8 and 17
i mean do we have to acknowledge that as
a scheme it actually caused some
problems
i'm not sure that i would accept that
analysis but of course i'd look at
uh any evidence that comes but you're
right to say that there's a global
pandemic
we learn the lessons as we go with any
virus which is new
and of course one of the big things
compared to where we were in february
march is that we've got a huge amount
more learning
the testing and tracing capacity that
we've got is now
close to five hundred thousand per day
so uh
we in a stronger position in that
respect we we know more about the virus
we've made the preparations for the nhs
we saw in the first lockdown we
preserved
uh nhs capacity we continue to work very
hard at that
we we can also take the economic
measures to provide people businesses
and employees uh
self-employed with the support that they
need so we you're absolutely right to
say that we will learn
all the time we learn in this country we
learn the lessons from further afield
across
uh across the world and that's the right
approach i think that's what
people would expect i just wonder if i'm
wondering quite how to phrase this
minister but it about it's about
carrying the people with you
isn't it in all of this you did that
very well
during the national lockdown people you
know really sort of obeyed the rules
in the main and we saw you know a very
big improvement in the figures
and i know ministers like yourself have
talked to um don't know how many of you
over the last few months and you all say
well most people are
following the rules you only have to
walk out to
any high street any shopping center and
you see
that is not the case people aren't
behind this anymore
how do you get people back in step with
what needs to be done
well i do accept that as things uh
continue uh people's become people
become weary
with the state of play but i also think
there is a very strong latent sense of
understanding that we're in
an unprecedented global pandemic which
the likes of which we've never seen
before and
and of course it's the job of the media
to pick up on one or other area where
things aren't going well and
and it's right that our feet are held to
the fire but i can tell you i'll be out
in my constituency
uh uh down in uh stoked avenue on the
high street i
do this every week talking to retailers
talking to businesses
and actually i the thing that we hear is
that we understand
this is an incredibly difficult
situation but the gov and the
government's gonna get criticized
whatever it does
but there's a lot of understanding that
uh the support is being put in place and
the approach that we're taking
is the right one and overwhelmingly
people
are following the rules of course
there's some weariness with it of course
there's some testing at the edges and as
rules change
the the challenge is to keep the clarity
of message but i think the country does
understand the predicament we're in
and people do not want to end up in a
national lockdown so the number one
thing to do right now
is in whatever local area you're in
follow the guidance follow the rules the
government's providing the support
that's the way we get through this and
we will get through this there will be
light at the end of the tunnel but but
it's it's about
guidance being clear yeah i have to say
from from a personal point of view i got
annoyed
during lockdown when people said the
guidance wasn't clear because it seemed
pretty clear to me
when we're in national lockdown it's not
clear to me now
i mean it's very confusing i mean every
tier three area has got different sets
of
rules there needs to be some proper
proper
clarity here which doesn't seem to just
doesn't seem to be there at the moment
well i don't agree with that or although
i understand the the challenge
that people have but the reality is you
can go online and check
absolutely precisely and definitively in
your area
what the restrictions are but if we
followed your advice stephen and i take
it very seriously
um we'd end up with uh for the sake of
clarity with a one-size-fits-all
approach
that wouldn't be the most effective way
of tackling the virus and what we've got
to do with
laser-like focus is is concentrate on
how we get the virus down and that is a
targeted approach a focused approach
yes i understand we need to have a clear
message but i think people do understand
that
the the that we've got to be take a more
nuanced approach
uh where the virus is the strongest and
that's the thing that will pull us
through
and we will get through this uh we will
get through this with the testing and
tracing that we're ramping up
with the scope for vaccine and
therapeutics the drugs that
take the reduce the fatality rate of
this disease
and we just got to stick with it and
it's tough and it's wearing and i
appreciate the impact on people's lives
and their livelihoods but we will get
through this and
i'm confident the approach the
government has taken the targeted
approach
the focused approach is the right one